who is the Rainman interesting title
Rainman why Rainman we're gonna find out
so what's going on I'm GNA I'm going to
click to this picture here and what are
we seeing
here
so we are say seeing the elements that's
why we're talking about this we're going
to be identifying some of the elements
the symbols the different names of gods
that Bale worship takes the form of okay
so notice the goat the pentagram
the allseeing eye will come into play
they kind of um infer that there's an
eye an third eye on that goat yeah this
is a AI created image so it's like it's
only doing what you put in there but
yeah I see a lot of stuff going on I see
there's a symbol behind the goat head
yeah that's um actually a mapping of the
zodiac signs and the stars and moons and
overlaying um Planet worship along with
Bill worship that's really we're going
to get into that as well probably in
other
presentations um we're right now we're
laying the foundation of understanding
these things before we get into more
depth awesome okay so let's move on so I
just want to mention that why are we
speaking about this yeah mainly
because for those who don't
know well we've been deceived we don't
really see it in our culture today as is
obvious a lot of us have been numb to it
when we do see it um and we have to know
what it looks like if we're not going to
be deceived by it all and the the Bible
says let no man deceive you that's right
so we want Eyes Wide Open to see what
we're going to see and I have depictions
of this
because in all of
its Gore and nastiness grotesque
explicitness yes we are going to see
just
how disgusting it all is because it's
necessary it is necessary because when
we're always cloaking everything as a
culture yeah in positivity and dressing
things up to always have the right
artistic expression yeah that's what I
hear a lot you know people like they'll
do this blatant Satanic ritual on stage
at a Grammys award or this uh Euro award
thing and then they're like oh it's just
artist artistic expression right but
most of the time it's because we all are
told not to speak unless we can sound
like we're positive and manicured or
cultured all the time right uh we want
to be civilized and that's what I hear a
lot about when we expose things like you
know Dragon Ball they worship the dragon
and the dragon is Satan and and there's
all these other elements too but they're
like you guys are racist that's their
culture I'm like look you can't say that
sin is cultural and it's acceptable
there's cultures that um they approve of
incest pedophilia all these things are
we going to say that that's just culture
you can't you can't excuse sin by saying
it's cultural and I think that's one of
Satan's tricks right there yeah it's not
a cop out you can't use that as a cop
out that's right so um a lot of the time
nakedness this is another thing worship
of the goat uh goat headed God as Bale
or a bull um is going to be seen along
with these symbols of the pentagram and
lots of people you see a child um in
front there by the altar on the image
to the right and as we're going to get
into it you'll see why um the Bible
tells us in the next
slide
that um we're just going to cover real
quick the names of Bale because we have
to understand that as well so the name
Bale
actually means owner Lord or husband
it's a complete counterfeit for Yahweh
exactly yeah because Jesus is supposed
to be our owner our Lord our husband but
I'll have to go look at the Bible verse
but there's a Bible verse that actually
talks about this and says if you
contrast the way they describe Satan and
the way they describe God as our Lord
husband and owner it's loving Satan it's
all demanding it's an Overlord it's it's
somebody who's actually a slave master
oh yeah that would make a difference
yeah if a slave calls his master Lord
because he's this slave master but we
call God our Lord out of reverence yeah
and love respect right and so I often
hear that you know when people say Don't
call God or Jesus Lord because that
means bail Lord is a is a title and Baal
is um a gen generic term for Lord or
Lord is a generic term for Bale but when
you say God is my Lord that's saying
that's just like God is my God his name
is Yahweh but we call him God capital G
because he is our God that's our title
and so this baale and Lord and all that
stuff is the same way too right so in
symbolism as I mentioned it's a bull a
goat a ram even or a half human mix of
one of one or all of the
things um he's mainly known as a god of
fertility weather and rain we're going
to look at rain he's called
Rainman and he also is represented by
wind lightning Seasons war and soldiers
wow so in satanic worship or even more
of the the um official term for that
type of statue and image of Bale is
baffet they give the definition right
there actually um humanoid goat creature
most notable figure in Satanism this is
actually the official logo type for the
Church of Satan yeah the BFF right yeah
and I I see this picture in the top left
and I recognize that from the Rihanna
music video exactly uh this is around
the time that God really opened my eyes
December 11 is when God just knocked the
blinders off my eyes the scales came off
my eyes stood me up out of my seat and I
could no longer just look at
entertainment and music as just like
meaningless things it all had meaning it
all had symbolism and in this music
video uh that's the Umbrella music video
if I'm not mistaken and um all of a
sudden she's standing in a triangle and
she bends down in this I've heard
humanly impossible pose and her arms
look like horns and there's these pits
in her shoulders that look like eye
sockets and it literally looks like a a
demon head and I don't think that's by
accident no whether it was CG in post or
straight demonic you know I think Satan
can contort people and make things
happen visually on screen oh yeah for
sure um you're right whether it was one
or the other I know from the dancing
background that I come from I could do
all kinds of things when I was under the
influence of just letting the music take
me yeah and use me I could too I mean
people out there don't know your story
story but a lot of people have heard my
testimony and when me and my friend
would make music we we refused to do it
sober we preferred being high on
marijuana but we would do alcohol if we
had it or didn't have weed but um he
would play the guitar I don't I won play
a single instrument I can program music
but he would play the guitar and I would
just Freestyle lyrics they would just
come out of my mouth and they were they
rhymed they made sense and they were
most of the time Blasphemous because at
that time idolized Mar Manon Nish Nails
Cradle of Filth and I wanted to be like
those people and I truly believe that
demons were working through me because I
can't freestyle anymore you know
sometimes I I'll feel like I can't I
start and I'm like I can't even rhyme
another word and I believe that when you
are messing with that stuff you're
messing with marijuana which you see uh
Native Americans they smoke a peace pipe
not for recreational use they're doing
it as a worship ceremony and when you
drink Spirits it's literally called
spirits right and we live in denial
about it like oh it's not demonic you
know and try to justifi As Long As I
don't get drunk well where where's the
level where do you draw the line with
drunk you know I'm just Tipsy or
whatever anyway all that to say so
you're talking about you did hip-hop
dancing I was I was a hip-hop dancer I
got into it heavily in college um one
day I'll share that story but I could
get up on stage
and do all kinds of moves that I'd never
done before and I don't remember a whole
lot of it I'd actually lose my memory
and it was like I wasn't present at that
moment W um but then as I even just
exiting stage and walking down the
stairs again it would come to me my
Consciousness would kind of come back to
kind of like waking up from a dream and
it's coming back to you like oh yeah I
do remember doing that backflip or
whatever yeah and then you're told what
you did like those kinds of things
backflip and you're like oh my goodness
or or some things were not appropriate I
will be honest but you were doing things
that you didn't even think you could do
right that's right that's really
interesting so that's the same you know
I was freestyling I couldn't do that I
can't do that you couldn't do a flip or
something maybe but you did it on stage
and so we hear this all the time you
know Beyonce says I can't sing like that
um but when when I lift my hands to the
spirit Sasha Fierce comes into me and
she can be loud and bold and strong and
she can do things that I can't do she
said that yeah if we had the clip we'd
play it but you guys are familiar with
the clip look it up uh look up Beyonce
Sasha fears also I just had another
thought what was it
[Music]
um anyway but yeah she she says that
when she gets on stage she does things
that she can't do what I was going to
say was you talked about not being able
to remember stuff there are people
that's coming out now that people these
go to these concerts like Taylor Swift
and they can't remember the concert it
says postc concert Amnesia and it's
happening at Taylor Swift and I think
the other one was Beyonce how can you
not remember a concert I've been to many
and I've been to them drunken high and
metal music all that and I don't not
remember them so yeah I don't know if
it's all music or if there's something
different going on right now but it's
pretty interesting H so are we going to
look at another slide or you got more on
this one we got more to cover real quick
um so you're right that was from the
Rihanna music video
um there's just the pictures of baffet
on the right there and down below is a
image of the actual statue that they put
up in like government buildings around
the world yeah that was molok it is it's
molok and they usually have but molok
and Bale are like interchangeable
they're the same Yeah because sometimes
I see the owl molok you know um at the
Bohemian Grove they worship molok that
owl yes but it's it's Bale because Bale
is sometimes an owl too yes yeah so it
does take on different forms different
images that represent them we're going
to talk about that we're going to get
into it more deeply um I was just going
to mention that image we were talking
about on the bottom um usually in other
places it's either like that where you
can see that there's swas swastikas oh
yeah um on his hands his palms wow um it
might not be zoomed in enough for that
but it usually has two children one male
one female standing on either side of
him near his arms and looking up to him
wow oh yeah you're talking about those
bamus statues that are popping up yes
okay so let's get back to what it says
on the slide I just want to cover it
real quick just in case for clarity um
he's also known as be elub in
demonology um of course Satan
mahit uh bafu Marius Samuel Lilith
that's an interesting one goat of Mendes
sabatical
goat goat of lust and a zazil goat a
zazil yeah so that's interesting it
gives you little tidbits in the names of
what how dirty and disgusting he is um
you can go to the next
slide okay so let's kind of dig into
what Rainman means here um this is
actually definitions from exposing the
music industry if you've not seen that
documentary um it's in Parts on YouTube
it's kind of hard to find too if you
can't find it on YouTube go to rumble or
bitshoot that's where when you're
looking at stuff like this stuff that
exposes you know the music industry
Hollywood the government conspiracy type
stuff if you can't find on YouTube check
out rumble or bitshoot
right um I encourage people to actually
watch those um Parts one through 10 it's
really worth it he explains everything
about what's going on and the worship
that's really occurring and everything
he really breaks down Point by Point
symbolism in the music videos it's
really interesting I mean like I
remember uh during the umbrella video he
was pausing it while he showing like the
water droplets and showing just how
detailed these um you know the the post-
production are at at putting symbols in
the moving water I mean it's crazy yeah
to reveal other symbols that he goes
through um so when rain is used here
it's when it's used as an individual's
name it actually takes on another
meaning all by itself the name rain
means Abundant Blessings from above it
can be used in various ways to mean
someone who offers Abundant Blessings
from above someone who likes to Make It
Rain which means throwing money um in
the air basically for a stripper or for
L basically to fulfill L right right um
and someone who can give you any man or
woman you desire someone who can make
you rich or famous that's all that you
see in music videos people are always
doing that but it's a nod to who you're
worshiping when you call yourself the
rain man you do these gestures it
actually means that you are giving
credence honor and you're venerating
Satan or Bale yeah and He blesses you it
seems like the more disgusting in and
grotesque and the more symbolism and
signs you can Flash up like the horns
when people do that with their
hands Satan actually seems to tune in
it's like you're giving away parts of
yourself more and more to that deception
I think it's an invitation you know you
you put Idols in your home that's an
invitation you drink you you mess around
with drugs these are all things that are
inviting the enemy into your home into
your life because Satan has no dominion
over us MH it's like the whole vampire
myth you know they they can they can't
come into your door until you give them
permission until you invite them in
that's where that all comes from it's
demonology and so I I think there's many
different ways that we do it un
unknowingly unaware you know it could be
uh some dream catcher even that so I
know of a vacation bible school type
thing that was happening and they made
dream catchers and I was just like man
you know I just saw like 30 of them and
in the room and I was just like man this
is so bad but they weren't there I
couldn't even talk to anybody about it
it was just I saw a room where all the
kids had made them and they were still
in the room and I was like man this is
an invitation for for Satan to come into
your life These Are Spiritual things and
so sometimes it could be a dream catcher
it could be some Crystal you're wearing
it could be a Buddha statue you got from
you know TJ Maxx or something these
things have become so culturally
acceptable that we just think oh it's
just decoration but it's really an idol
in your home and when you look up in the
Bible about idols and having an idolatry
the Bible strictly forbids it and is
it's it's a very terrible sin because
not because God is um full of himself
some narcissist but because you're
inviting demon Spirits into your home
you're giving them access yeah yeah so
[Music]
um I don't know it's just really
interesting because they use his name
they use the name Rainman to refer to
themselves we'll see a video in just a
minute here on that and it's amazing
because
well again I got this from exposing the
music industry and they say exactly in
there Rainman is the devil she is
Satan well yeah every every false god is
Satan or demons I mean we just read it
in the Bible this morning we reading in
Acts and Paul said that it was talking
about um not eating Meats offered to
Idols or maybe you can eat Meats we were
trying to actually discuss that like we
were seeing at one point it said you
know don't do these things abstain from
these things eating meats that were
offered to Idols eating meats that were
strangled um or have blood in them and
avoid fornication and all these things
and then later though somewhere else
Paul is saying that these meats offered
to Idols they don't don't have any power
in them so it's okay to eat them but
don't eat them if it's going to make
your brother stumble because he's weak
in the faith so that that's what we were
looking at that was the context but in
there it said that the meat offered to
Idols is worshiped to is is offered to
Demons it literally says it plain as day
in the Bible so we can you know I've
always just assumed that and said that
that Idols are literally demons but the
Bible literally says it spells it out
plainly so there's no you know mystery
to it right so one last point there um
it's actually a very important one
because it can help you start knowing
when they're actually I identifying
themselves or kind of linking themselves
to bail worship is using the words like
I said Rainman
rain um umbrella Ella and
a those are the ones that we know of so
far um so we'll go ahead and go to the
next slide and watch the video okay so
what's your name be
Rainman
[Music]
missh and change the forecast your
boyfriend is lame I Make It Rain On
You I just ran out of money I need to
,000 cash
it and you know it take it it
[Music]
it wow yeah it's so crazy because I I
think Satan has so many ways of hiding
worship to him and that's that's where
he doesn't play fair God is knocking on
the door of our hearts he wants us to
open the door he's not tricking us he's
not trying to bash indoors where Satan
is using deception deceit uh trickery
every trick in the book and he's trying
to get into your home like oh it's just
uh you know it's just this or that like
right it's just a little art statue yeah
or it's just fun yeah it's just a little
fun you know take a little drink or
whatever it is but he he disguises
everything he even in Hollywood you know
it's like follow your heart oh it sounds
so beautiful which is really just do
what thou Wilt but in the Disney form
and so you think about if Bale is the
god of rain and prosperity and all these
things with a perfect disguise you know
rain man I'm call me to rain man because
I Make It Rain I throw money on women or
whatever and and you you use it as some
like status but really these people are
Satan worshippers yeah and so B worship
is Satan worship
MH so it's everywhere with that but if
we trace it back to its Origins again um
if you can go to the next
slide we're going to break this down
because um by the way if you want to
know more of the backstory of this um
where I explain more about pagan origins
and kind of where Nimrod comes from
because he's of the line of Noah um and
how that comes traces back to the flood
and then we go forward from there please
go ahead and stay tuned I'm going to be
covering pagan origins in an
upcoming um video basically and we'll
just help you understand it more so hit
that subscribe button hit that
notification Bell and keep up because
we're going to be coming out with videos
all the time so
mhm okay so we'll just do a little
overview really quickly here so you have
the flood you have um Noah with his two
his three sons on the ark and his family
and Satan just has to play with somebody
so he gets into the mind of ham ham
seemed to be the perverted one who
actually took pleasure in seeing his
father naked um insinuating that he
liked what he saw yeah um that's
disgusting so you have that perversion
within him that seems to grow and he has
a son named Kush and Kush has a son
named Nimrod and Nimrod is you know that
many generations away from the promises
of God that he would save the people
from another flood he would never flood
the Earth again and you would think that
they would be you know understanding the
love of God and how good he is and
everything but
instead he hates God's law he's tired of
keeping the Sabbath and he's tired of
keeping the Ten Commandments and being
good he actually kills his father and
marries this is Nimrod by the way he
kills his father and he marries his
mother samiramis so now you have a
mother wife
situation so the first incest is
occurring and this
is he is the founder of baale worship um
and we get Babylon he's the one who set
up the Tower of Babel and then it became
known as
Babylon um he also went to go set up he
became known as the father of many other
towns along with
Nineveh um many of the towns that are
against the Lord in the Bible which
again we'll cover in other videos but
but he
was again so against God he wanted the
counterfeit religion so we have a
trinity there the first Trinity that we
hear of because if we really know what
we're talking about in the Bible there
Trinity the word Trinity doesn't exist
in the Bible yeah so we have Nimrod as
the son God or the the ruler the king of
Babylon you have samiramis as the moon
goddess and queen of on and you have
their child that they had named tamuz
now how he was conceived we will get
into that as well but Babylon of course
is known as confusion or the Gate of the
Gods that's important I don't know if
that rings a bell or that starts making
you think but it should because what
what part gate of the Gods gate of the
Gods because basically you only had
excuse me you only
had worship of God the true God Yahweh
and then all of a sudden you have bail
worship yeah and
then it turns into many different things
all these different cultures after that
many different names many different
statues that all come from bail worship
they're all the same thing yeah and it
all goes to Sun worship and Sun worship
is Satan worship yes and that's a good
point because if you can identify any
religion that has quite honestly an idol
in it
um Sun worship serpent worship oh yeah
um Dragon worship Dragon worship and did
I already say fire no you said Sun but
fire okay fire worship you have
identified Satan at the core you know I
think it's interesting that when we talk
about Dragon Ball Z and Anime and they
worship dragons and all these things and
the dragon is the serp or the dragon is
Satan and people are like oh it's
culture isn't it interesting that all
around the world the Bible says that
that dragon that old serpent is the
devil and Satan the dragon and The
Serpent and we know Baal and the Sun and
all these things too but all around the
world we just happen to see cultures
that worship the serpent like the Mayans
the dragon like the Chinese and the
Japanese I think it's interesting that
all around the world we see serpent
worship Dragon worship Sun worship it's
not a coincidence and people want to to
say oh it's just culture Satan has
deceived the whole world that's it says
that the dragon was cast down and he's
going to deceive the entire world and if
you look for it you can see it plain as
day and it's even in
America yeah and and sometimes it's
pretty bold blatant you know we
got so many of these artists are just
coming out now they're not even hiding
it you know they're they're at the
Grammys and they're all wearing devil
horns and there's fire everywhere and
and um yeah it's really just crazy how
Satan doesn't even hide anymore and
people still want to be in denial about
it
yeah yeah it's crazy um but let's just
dive a little deeper into this origin
story what about the Queen of Heaven
There did you talk about that not yet
not yet so let's just say that he set up
a um counterfeit system that because if
you're going to create a religion you
have to create the steps of the system
right so he created sacrifice of babies
and children to the Statue of Baal in
fire um the counterfeit of course of God
having told us we wanted he wanted
animals to be sacrificed um and that he
was the
eventual ultimate sacrifice for our sins
he also set up a counterfeit day which
is Sunday again yeah think about it sun
and day you're really worshiping the sun
um put in place as a counterfeit day of
worship in Rebellion against God's
Sabbath y um
so that's why I have up there it's a
birth of Satan's Church really this is
where it all began it became a big
system um
so let me get into it a little further
when Nimrod killed his father and
married his mother making her his wife
um there was Shem I don't know if you
know Shem um Shem is
basically
the uncle then of nimrod a faithful the
son of of Noah that was faithful along
with japheth and um they're loyal to God
and he
actually goes after Nimrod and cuts him
down with a
sword and um bail worship was in full
swing but then all of a sudden Nimrod is
killed by Shem and God actually is all
for it like it was a just killing yeah
and all of the people are afraid so they
go into um the underground basically
they take their religions underground
and that becomes the beginning of secret
societies oh wow so all secret societies
became a thing at that moment yeah um
and then different regions had their own
version of it perhaps or their different
Lodge and their different names for
their um secret societies Bohemian Grove
and the Bible does talk about those who
are in The Groves and they're eating the
mouse and this stuff hiding behind a
tree eating a mouse and all that I was
trying to think if the Bible ever talks
about secret societies but it does talk
about the secret Chambers yes you know
it says if they say he's coming in the
East or in the desert go not and it says
if he's in the secret Chambers and I'm
like does this mean that Satan
impersonating Christ will be among
secret societies and stuff Poss
possibly um but when that happen so
nimron is no longer alive Samir miss his
mother and
wife then in in some way she's actually
um she wants glory for herself she wants
attention she wants to be known as a a
queen yeah of Babylon still so she wants
all power to herself so she actually
makes herself a deified queen of
Babylon she pronounces herself that I've
just voted myself Queen yes and their
son which is kind of like an
illegitimate son they don't know where
if she was unfaithful or whatever but
she's pregnant oh wow suddenly and they
have a child or she does I guess at that
point named tamuz however what she does
is she takes all these priests and she
sets them up priests just listen to that
again yeah okay not all denominations I
know this sounds weird but so Queen of
Heaven already that terminology sounds
familiar and okay PRS uhhuh and she
confessionals yeah oh wow and these
booths are only for these ordained
priests who get you to confess
everything to them so that they can go
to her and tell you all about each
person in the town so that she can use
people wow she uses fear extortion and
Magic against them and all the priests
had to be versed in all of that yeah
deeply yeah we still see that in the
Catholic Church we see um they call Mary
the Queen of Heaven There You Go and so
it's like isn't it interesting if you
just looked up the Queen of Heaven in
the Bible you would see that this is a
false god yeah and then they have the
priests the
confessionals and they use the fear you
know that the Catholic church is all
about using fear and Penance and if you
don't pay money your family members are
going to burn and burn and burn in
purgatory and all these things and
that's why this country was founded to
to flee that persecution back in the the
papacy was ruling the world they would
kill you if you didn't convert and so
the the people that founded this country
were fleeing persecution and and came to
a land where there was freedom of
religion it's not a Christian Nation
maybe some of the people were Christian
but George Washington was a Freemason um
it's not a conspiracy theory it's true
and this country was founded on freedom
of worship you can worship whoever
however you want uh without facing you
know death decree or being burnt at the
stake and
so we see that there is going to be a
swing towards forc worship again that's
what the Bible says in Revelation that
it's going to come a time where they
will force worship with the death decree
and a lot of people think it's going to
be that there's going to be like some
oneman Antichrist that just hates
Christianity is going to be killing
Christians everywhere but it's going to
be a lot more deceptive than that a lot
of Christians are going to fall into
this STP because it's going to look like
peace and safety and it says when when
they say peace and safety sudden
destruction will come upon them it's
going to look like unity and love and
coexist and we can all agree on you know
something on love or whatever yeah and
if you stand on thus sayeth the Lord and
this is what the Commandments say and
this is what God says in his word you
will be Public Enemy Number One You're
the problem you're the reason there's so
much hatred and um intolerance and all
these things that these these terms that
are going around now hate speech and
tolerance these are all whether I don't
think that people know it as Satan is
working behind the scenes he's like okay
this group I'm going to get them to work
on intolerance this group I'm gonna get
them and he's working with all these
different groups to create these these
laws against hate speech and intolerance
and all these things so that when this
one world system is set up you cannot
speak the truth you can't stand on truth
because now if you say this lifestyle is
a sin you could be locked up for that
you don't you don't accept people well
that's what I just began with right I
said we always have to be tolerant and I
don't know civilized in the way we say
things that it's basically curtailing
everything we say yeah so that we're
never actually telling the truth and
even if we are it's just that was bad or
that was evil yeah that's it um but
sorry I think we're getting off track a
little bit um so the other point to make
is that she claimed she even told all of
her priests she laid it right out there
that the ideology was that they were the
only way to actually connect you with
God to mediate for
you and of course as we know that
mediation didn't even happen with them
it actually happened with Mary in their
system
yeah so anyway they had to take secret
Oaths they had to be in Magic and
deception and everything else and like
you said she was known as the Queen of
Heaven even to this day in the Catholic
church she is and the Bible has a lot to
say about the Queen of Heaven oh yeah a
lot says they offer up cakes to her and
everything and we see that happening too
we can cover that that will be covered
in detail okay that's one of our
holidays by the way a little taste of
that and wet your appetite wow
so when people went into hiding the um
these bail worship people and the
priests they all fled to the island of
Alexandria and they did not leave behind
their religion they actually honed their
skills in every evil disgusting satanic
occult thing the aisle of Alexandria who
are these people these are the the
secret societies and all the people who
practice bail worship at that time they
were afraid just like um Nimrod that
Shem and other Bible belie leing
Christians or God's people would come
and slaughter them all wow so they all
fled there and when they did they got to
live there for several years and they
actually made if you go to the next
slide they actually made this whole
Library of Alexandria that holds all the
occult books oh wow now it did burn down
eventually wow but a lot of those books
are still some of the books that certain
secret societies hand down to
Generations I bet to learn how to do
things to that's where they're always
trying to get you back to is the the
height of the knowledge of that day
where everything was almost in
fulfillment the knowledge of Good and
Evil yeah God was never keeping us from
knowledge he just didn't want us to have
the knowledge of evil rightfully so why
should we have knowledge of rape and
murder and all these
things all
right so as I said it was in full swing
we got to see it uh now we're going to
actually look at it as it spread across
the world in Egypt samiramis became
known as Isis um the Queen of Heaven and
Nimrod became known as Osiris the
husband's son and frequently is called
Horus the sun god in Phoenicia samiramis
and tamuz were worshiped as or known as
asth and
tamuz um in Greece Aphrodite and Aeros
in Rome Venus and Cupid and in China
mother Shing muu and her child we always
see this and those are only a few
examples it goes across I'll I'll show
you a picture of all the different names
of gods and it's not extensive there's
many more that I forgot or don't know
about even sometimes or whatever it is
um it's pretty good list but there's
always a a consort and we need to know
what that word means consort means a
wife husband or companion in particular
the spouse of a reigning monarch at that
time oh wow so why is that because again
they want to have that Trinity going on
you have the male God version of that
God which of course in bail worship is
Nimrod you have the female counterpart
which in this case is Samus and you have
a child there's always a child related
to this yeah so that kind of covers that
slide um
next this is this this list that I have
made um as we saw this is the confusion
where everything got confused because
people are now coming from all different
parts of the world even today even in
their time going well we worship Isis in
this one town and well we worship this
one God named Rihanna or Anana in our
town and she might look a little
different but we do the same things
isn't that strange I think she might be
the same yeah right well today is the
same thing too you can actually Trace
back different symbols different looks
of the idol even and different rituals
that are all all bound together yeah so
here's a list I hope that's helpful to
you guys again I've already um
delineated that Nimrod was the sun god
in this um picture samiramis was the
moon goddess and their child tamuz was
um tamuz really but is associated with
the
Stars pan on there it's interesting
because if you look up pan he's a Greek
god with goat legs and horns and he
plays the Pan Flute pipes yeah and this
is you know another example of when
Disney puts out these disgusting things
and sugarcoats them and makes them
kidfriendly where you have a a man a boy
named Peter Pan that flies up to Wendy's
window and says you know imagine your
daughter's upstairs asleep your young
daughter maybe pre- teen maybe barely a
teen yeah and some teenage boy flies up
to her window and says come with me
Wendy I want to take you to where the
lost boys are and there's no parents and
no rules and the only thing is is you
can never come back I mean this is Pan
the the uh P Piper you know all these
stories are so dark and a lot of people
are aware of this now that these nursery
rhymes and all these things have these
dark Origins and so why would you take a
a God Like pen who is a sexual deviant
the god of rape and all these things and
turn them into a beloved character on
Disney I will add to that to put it in
full kind of to burst the bubble any
mystery behind that he's not only a
rapist but a pedophile so that's really
what he's known for is doing that to
everybody he comes across um adult child
and whatever yeah so it's kind of like
Never Never Land the um you never go
back because your innocence has been
taken from you I think Michael Jackson
lived in Never Never Land had that theme
park and everything
yeah um
so this is really what it looked like
throughout history um different
variations of different chambers of
course the middle one showing multiple
chambers within one um more as a bull
head that is a uh it's a furnace right
it is it is a furnace and this would be
where people would offer up their
children yes mainly babies but the
chambers usually are big enough to
accommodate
a a fulls siiz
human
um there's another depiction right below
it that actually shows the offering up
of a baby in the black and white photo
there that's the one where you you see
it's like a bronze statue that's got
fire and I hear that the hands would
just be glowing red hot and they'd set
the babies on there yeah to just be
tortured to
death yes and I I'll be honest I get my
research uh not not just from Christian
websites but this is actually from
a Satan Satanist website and um that
image they were there was a woman who
had come out of Satan worship and she
actually said not that she had they had
the statue and they had everything but
they actually did this ritual and she
just remembers the
screams and I could understand that
that's a terrible thing to think about
and the horror of that um but that's
they used to play Such loud tambourines
and drums and everything off to the side
for that very reason so that you
wouldn't be um your emotions wouldn't
rise up and actually have sympathy and
care I hear that's kind of the origin of
the drums where they come from the skin
that was stretched over the bonga or
whatever I don't I don't think any
instrument is inherently evil I think
it's all about how you play it it's just
like anything a knife is not evil if
you're cutting vegetables with it but it
can be used to sacrifice your son or
something right so we'll just move along
a little quicker here um the next one we
were no no sorry back to yeah so we
still have the one I mentioned where the
two kids are standing there looking up
at the goat head guy on the far left um
again that's what governments are using
certain governments he's also the
fertility god with that that um
harvesting tool in his hand the Green
Man and just the the bull I guess the
top right at the top right yeah it's
depicted there um but anal sex is one of
the
key key forms of worship to ba um he's
also known at the very top you can see
as B balal balum and balum within AG so
it's mainly between it was known between
Bale I mean sorry male and male
worshippers to have this intercourse
like that yeah um it's really the only
way well you could do it with a FAL you
can but yeah it was mainly known between
males and males and it was offered up as
a sacrifice to the goddess basically it
meaning the waste the the Act
and the poop that came out U we're going
to talk about that in just a second so
yeah you know Satan loves to pervert
everything that God's
created God created sex it's a beautiful
thing that a married couple can
experience and you're only supposed to
experience it with one person in your
whole life many of us have not done it
that way unfortunately but imagine if we
did it God's way one man one woman
that's the only one you'll ever be with
and you get to experience this amazing
thing with just that one person you've
never experience with anybody else in
your life uh if we did it that way you
never have any comparing or any of that
stuff and Satan comes along and and it's
it has a purpose for one there's
pleasure and bonding and all that stuff
but it does create life and so Satan
comes along and says oh this thing that
God made I'm going to completely pervert
it to where you're going in a hole that
waste is supposed to come out of it's
completely unsanitary causes disease
infection all these things
and he turns it into this ritual
practice for him so you know God says
the marriage bed is undefiled and he
created it's this beautiful thing that
he made a gift now Satan says this act
is for me and
um yeah go ahead it's a circle of life
that God gave us it's beautiful like
you're saying it's supposed to be and
Satan goes H extra flesh now it's a
Circle of Death you know what I mean
yeah so it's like he is he's just
perverting every single thing and it's
it's amazing that this is another yet
another thing that we accept as a
culture that this is just a lifestyle
you're born this way you can't help it
uh it's it's beautiful it's love
whatever and um really it's just
glorifying and accepting satanic worship
a Satanic ritual
so they actually had Temple prostitution
between you could choose a male you
could choose a female you could choose a
crossdressing uh prostitute as well um
and sex with especially anal sex was
very glorifying to
Bale um in those prostitution
brothel and I just want to bring to
attention that it's actually
mentioned um that even after
years and
years that in Leviticus it's mentioned
here what you have a verse on Apostle
Paul yeah references this Pagan Worship
in Romans there it is Romans 1 26- 27
when he actually tears apart the same
kind of fertility goddess worship wow
yeah man the Bible has answers for
everything it's amazing
how how it's so applicable to our dayto
day when you really get into it and
read so we can go to the next
slide now and as you can
probably put together in your own minds
the lgbtq plus whatevers and everything
quite honestly that falls beneath that
started at bail worship yeah um there's
nothing new Under the Sun the Bible the
Old
Testament forbids homosexuality so it's
nothing new and gor was way back that's
in Genesis the first book of the Bible
talks about
homosexuality and we see where that led
to oh yeah so anyway this honors Bale
Queen of Heaven it also became known as
and this is where I want to get into
this she became known as ashth Ashira um
estarte Anana and Ishtar so keep that in
mind okay then in Mesopotamian nature
the ideal Pagan priests pertaining to
being lgbtq is actually both male and
female or
androgynous um I will be covering
actually the whole topic of lgbtq later
in an upcoming video as well um it's my
androgyny video so stay tuned for that
um I explained a lot more and the
spiritual applications to being involved
in a lifestyle like that yeah um the god
an which is um also Mesopotamian was all
she had all androgynous priests then
there's cybel Ria and they all refuse to
be one gender they would not be they
would be gender neutral yeah always wow
so non-binary fluid all these things
anything but what you were born of yes
um and yeah as you said it says right
there but possess character and physical
attributes of both wow and they would
even mutate themselves to do that wow
wow yes so this is nothing new nothing
new at all um I just want to make a huge
point of this because I mentioned it one
time there that in M Mesopotamia the
priests were said to need to be
androgynous but in wiah in the occult
and Satanism the highest level of
Witchcraft that you can
obtain like to commune with Satan and
the demons more fluidly again is
androgyny yeah I mean I it's crazy to me
that more people don't see this when you
go to these parades the lgbtq festivals
or whatever you will see them mocking
Christ you will see them wearing rainbow
devil horns you'll see the satanic
Church there with pentagrams that are
rainbows and it goes vice versa when you
go to the satanic
parades um you'll see the same thing
you'll see so much homosexuality there's
so many
rainbows because Satanism in that
lifestyle the lgbtq lifestyle go hand in
hand yeah they are it is a satanic
practice it's not just an alternate
lifestyle and well it's a little
different than it is satanic let's just
be blatantly honest that's exactly what
it is we saw literally where this stuff
came from that this is a a ritual
Satanic ritual and to me it's just so
clear you I see when I did a video on
the show ous a Disney ow house this was
before the main character came out as
bisexual by the way uh I was just
talking about how the the producer or
the the creator of the show said her
pitch to Disney was girl hangs out with
witch in hell that was her pitch and
Disney's like awesome let's do it and so
you you literally have the whole
environment is hell and a teenage girl
hanging out with a witch later becomes
bisexual why why is Witchcraft and
bisexual and so I remember when we
released that on Little Light
Studios we got flooded with comments of
different people saying be gay do
witchcraft be gay do witchcraft be gay
why why those two things hand in hand
because they are hand in hand exactly
and I'm going to uncover why that's
again I'm gonna show you why awesome in
my androgyny presentation later
awesome
so um that's the point I've covered all
that yeah we can go to the next one so
this is Anana oo them hips don't lie
yeah who does that look like today um
Kardashians so that was supposed to be
the most beautiful and of course she's
grabbing her own chest because she's
supposed to be the mother of many
nations and have many like
fertility and I've seen some of these
images where the woman has many breasts
like an animal we're going to look at
that too she's usually known under a
different name then it morphs to a
different name um this one one with
Anana is mostly seen with owls so oh
yeah you got her Bohemian Grove yep you
got her with owls with owl feet um with
the kind of ank in her hands um so
that's the connection there next slide I
see the sun oh you do right yes right
there okay that's right for the Seal of
Anana yeah that is the actual seal of
Anana in the middle now is it more to
cybell like you said many breasts oh
yeah is
colie she's not the only one is that
here it's kind of small is that it no
it's right here oh oh I see clearly so
they don't usually show klie like that
um or with the Cornucopia by the way is
collie sometimes a male
too no okay um I was thinking this was
the Hindu god that's like stomping on
the children and all that she's
technically an assassin who does do many
of those grotesque things but she's
always female okay so it's not the male
one gotcha there's another one I forget
what his name is uh but he has his own
stuff his own name if you guys haven't
ever watched a Walter vi video man he's
so deep but I remember him talking about
this hat that this guy has on this weird
Smurf hat The Smurfs wear it they're
also blue like this but it's a Fran cap
oh you know about that okay I couldn't I
can never remember what it's called but
I I've seen it on a seal yeah uh an army
seal like a circle do you know why I'm
sorry I'm going to pop this mystery
right here because that was the hat that
the Masons wore oh okay that makes sense
that was part of your initiation and
part of the way that they could tell
each other from the rest was the fraking
cap wow if you look like a Smurf you
were a Freeman yeah so when again
similar hats are being worn by the
dwarfs in in Snow White and and somewhat
of a variation with Peter Pan as well
with some of their caps yeah a nod to
the the Masons
interesting so um sybel is known with
lions you get to see her with lions um
and the sun went in the middle seal
again um what is most important part
about this um that's actually the tiny
little man with the beard
mhm that's actually one of her priests
that are androgynous wearing a dress and
having a beard wow um so is the guy with
the fry and cap on actually she he sorry
there you go you have the confusion
Babylon there you go yeah he is a priest
to a sbel can you not see that this is
our society today like literally like he
she what uh I don't even I don't want to
misgender you um you have a beard you're
wearing a dress I don't know right this
is this is Babylon you know the Bible
says that we're going to go back to the
days of Babylon you know Revelation is
written in symbols and it describes
God's people as Israel and the rest of
the world as Babylon and Babylon means
confusion right and man if we're not in
confusion today when people don't even
know what gender they are anymore it is
a confusing world yes so um that's her
anyway and um by the way just to mention
um the Madonna statue Madonna is another
name by the way just like cbel asth um
samiramis it's all a name of the female
counterpart or wife of nimrod which is
for bail worship oh W okay so um when
you see the other woman who has tons of
breasts on her usually it's a Madonna
statue they have black ones and they
have white ones right I've seen the
black Madonna yeah so next slide so this
is a an interesting point a hugely
interesting point because in cbell
worship again that's a male priest that
looks like a woman kind of
there's the Halo on her which you'll her
him sorry I don't know it looks like a
masculine face but feminine body I don't
know yeah is it a um and they were known
as goddesses a c Bel I'm sorry is the
goddess of thresholds transitions
transitions interesting and Street Raves
Street Raves she's hugely known for the
street Raves yeah we think that uh
raving is something new and like oh man
man I love to party and I'm you know hip
but my parents didn't know about that or
something but it's like dude you look at
I have these giant books they're like
this big this thick um of art from
Michelangelo and stuff and you see like
these people dancing in the streets
naked and it's all in Greek mythology
and all that too so it's nothing new uh
dance parties with nakedness and
drunkenness and in the streets like
Marty girl you know let me throw you
some beads and show me some skin and
we're in the middle of the street yeah
um which is by the
way again why would nakedness be showing
itself so many times in so-called art
throughout the ages because of pagan
worship yeah that's the only reason
yeah so let's see what is the next slide
so this is where it comes full circle we
actually have people today this is an
actual adver M I
found um several months back that says
we are an ancient people the queer
Spirit oh my goodness because we live
between male and female matter and
spirit the living and the dead quep
spirit. net yep and because we come from
all other peoples we were and are honor
honored in many cultures for our
capacity to link connect and unify we
have been called Gatekeepers and Bridge
Builders we are the walk between people
people a natural healing and
peacekeeping force in the world so now
bringing up another element of the
spiritual Powers which you will have or
usually is accompanied by being queer
yeah or LGBT or whatever is they're
usually known as healers that's really
interesting too um not too many years
back but maybe the early 2000s mid
2000s um or 2009 or whatever there's lot
more like atheist atheist was cool cool
to be an atheist and people were not
like just gay like they are you know
like it wasn't made trendy like it is
now I still don't think that the numbers
are inflated like they act like you know
if you judged how many homosexuals are
in the world by watching Hollywood you
would think 30% of the population is a
homosexual it's not anything like that
it might be 6% and that's all young
people
but also more and more people are
becoming spiritual less of them are
atheist now they're spiritual and it's
usually new age or wiah or something so
you have homosexuality rising and these
false systems of worship New Age and and
wicked what I'm getting at is this whole
being gay is Magic there's some kind of
magic in it there you go you should just
leave it there because that's like an
entire teaser to my androgyn okay video
so yeah I'll be walking through all of
that all throughout history
so um here's the Ashira poles or aarde
or Aster poles is it's all mentioned in
the bible as the same things they're
just different variations in different
countries so you would see them
sometimes as just poles like you see in
the center there that are kind of um
engraved with different patterns um you
would actually have different busts of
the people of course like which means
you know from the chest up yeah of
carvings of them you
have unfortunately like the man is
hewing out an entire um wood carving
that's pretty much a sex doll in the
Groves oh my goodness um and you would
of course you could use all these
they're free free sex dolls in in the
Groves and in the woods for their
practices and when you get down below
you get to the point where um the trees
this is a seen this before this is the
Anunnaki right Anunnaki marry tree wow
yes so we just say Merry Christmas that
it was merry tree um there you have the
actual um Christmas tree with little
elves climbing up it looks identical to
this yeah I mean the way it's designed
so that's a little taste of the holiday
presentations I will be giving monarch
butterflies up here yes is that a beetle
what is that that is a beetle I'm not
sure why okay um for that you just blew
my mind the Merry Christmas Merry tree
goes back to the anunaki yeah wow and I
will be covering that as because why do
we even say Merry Christmas we don't say
we say happy Halloween happy Easter why
do you say Merry right right it has to
have origin right okay so that's that
and of course I brought it all the way
to today with a lit tree there with
presents underneath it um so next slide
so I just want to touch a little bit on
this too because uh why do we have a
tree why do we cut down a tree bring it
into our home decorate with lights I've
seen a lot of different you know
speculation some of it might be
speculation I do believe that this goes
back to Sun worship again because the
evergreen tree it never died it's green
all year round and so they looked at
this tree as a symbol that the sun would
come back because during the winter time
it people got scared is is it going to
get colder and colder and colder and the
sun's never going to come back right but
the Evergreen was a symbol that a
promise basically that their son God
would return back because it always
stayed green yes and so now we bring
this in during the specific time of the
year which I believe is Pagan too and we
put offerings under it yes these
presents are offerings not to mention
the decorating which has so much more he
is mentioning just a few things I am
going to be unpacking that there's so
much more to this awesome in the holiday
presentations which I didn't you know
this is the long awaited holiday
presentation set that we never
um you never got to do them yet I never
got to do them when I was with little
light so tune in for that please so I
I've heard another cool speculation that
you know there's a a angel on top and
there's this Garland serpent around thee
tree with red things hanging from the
tree it's like the tree of knowledge of
Good and Evil the serpent tempting you
the angel that was guarding the tree um
there's all that's what I'm saying like
I'm not sure if that stuff speculation I
do believe what's not speculation is the
evergreen tree is a symbol of a promise
that the Sun God would return yes and
that you know that winter would end and
all those
things um so I'm bringing it full circle
again these are just to prove many
things here you have the middle picture
up top very high um highest picture and
with the anaki tree again um you have to
the right the Egyptian tree um the far
left top left is um I think Canaanite
down below is
Babylonian um again an Egyptian one in
the middle
and down
below um I forget which one that one is
but it's it's rather grotesque all of a
sudden it's like there's I don't know if
those are lions or beasts or even demons
alongside the tree um so I was just
trying to prove that it's in it's
showcasing itself in many different
cultures all through history yes nothing
new yes and today um there's a little
history on this in um the sh pole was it
was actually seen as a mound like this
which is more right in your face um an
image of the male genitalia mhm and um I
saw that with some of the other poles
back here too it kind of this looks very
male y um we'll see it even in more
application as we go forward but that's
what the um I'm sorry what the what is
the word for oh Obelisk that's what the
Obelisk is truly and and it was in India
they still have this it's actually a
little Idol you can get on your uh your
altar for the home altars um you can
actually get a tiny lingum I think is
what it's called it had the name on the
the and what is a lingam it's just like
that it's a mound of the
actual
phallic phace and so people in India
have this on their desk well in India
and the Indians who come to the United
States if they they worship this they
will actually pour milk over it which
signifies fertility the
ejaculation um which they're trying to
receive from the God they're trying to
have fertility and abundance again
that's Bale Rainman whatever yeah there
you go
Prosperity yes
and I you can read the rest of that but
it also had Shrine prostitution um which
is really what you do at that you again
these Mounds whatever they're called um
whatever they look like are always for
prostitution and
origies that's a a place to do
that so next slide this is what it
looked like in Egypt um when you said as
something as Astra as thinking of this
is that what that's called that's a
maple mapole okay and we have that's
what came to mind yes so someone made a
comment actually um about it still being
in Europe yes they do in England and in
Europe in some places they definitely
have mapole celebrations in which the
public can join in um mostly put on by a
lot of these occult or Satanist groups
or Solstice Keepers um and such and it
just always looks fun I always see kids
doing it but what is the significance is
there like choose your partner when you
get to the base of the pole or something
actually it's more grotesque than that
because every time your ribbon overlaps
with another person
they're your next partner oh my God and
it just keeps going on and on and on you
just keep until the pole is filled with
the
ribbon um and a little tiny flash of
this would be what we have on Easter
morning they would wait until the Sun
hits over the hills of a mountain or a
hill and they would have the sun um sun
rays hit their bodies in a frenzy uh to
capture this fertility from the gods
they would get to it like rabbits they
would just have the pole and everything
and that's why rabbits were the sun was
blessing them and they had to do it in
front of the Sun God yes yeah and yeah
exactly Rabbits and Eggs are all about
fertility there's another reason for the
rabbit and the eggs too but I again will
explain that in my holiday presentation
that interesting Playboy uses the rabbit
logo yeah so we can go to the next one
um again on this topic especially
referring to Aira AAR and asth the Bible
has so much to say about this um I just
mentioned these ones because it's it was
hard-hitting and much more um clear but
it says in Isaiah
57:5 you who burn with lust Among The
Oaks again it was among Hills and and
Groves trees right the wood Tre wood
wooded areas under every Green Tree you
said the Evergreen yeah wow okay who SL
Slaughter your children in The Valleys
Under The Cliffs of the
Rocks then I had the same version I'm
sorry the same verse in a different
version for the King James version and I
want you to hear its depth inflaming
yourselves with Idols that actually
inflaming actually seems to in my mind
ring true of again
this orgasm right right this orgy um
that's coming
inflaming yourselves with Idols under
every Green Tree slaying the children in
the valleys Under The Cliffs of the
Rocks then in Jeremiah verse 2 sorry 2
verse 20 we have here that it says long
ago you broke off your yoke and tore off
your bonds you said I will not serve you
indeed then I'm sorry indeed on every
high hill and under every spreading tree
you lay down as a prostitute
wow a lot about trees a lot about trees
and tree worship and and that's another
thing I would like to connect right now
is tree worship goes along with this a
lot of the time you have like The Druids
I will be showing this in just a moment
they're known
as they worship Oaks wow um wiccans when
certain holidays come around they will
actually put whether it's the holly
berry or a evergreen tree or a pine tree
you know what I mean they have different
trees for different uses actually during
the year to sacrifice or give to their
make their wand out of different types
of wood exactly Hol for different
reasons different things you're trying
to conjure up or do I wonder where that
word Hollywood comes from we say it so
like Hollywood I think of stars and
Glitz and glamour but it's yeah the The
Witches one made out of holly
hollywood is to lull people to sleep
because the holly berries are known to
make you fall asleep and so Hollywood is
just lulling its spell over Humanity as
it broadcasts casting a spell broadly
right yeah you have the Broadway on
Broadway and it's like but God says
Jesus says uh take the narrow way not
the Broadway the Broadway leads to
destruction yeah you got Sin City all
these things are like right in our face
when when it comes to like big cities
and stuff um it's all this stuff's
talked about in the Bible
yes yes so um that's what that slide was
showing now we're going to cover and
make another connection here actually
because in Ezekiel 8 verse1 17 it says
then he said unto me hast thou seen this
oh son of man is it a light thing to the
house of Judah that they commit the
Abominations which they commit here for
they have filled the land with violence
and have returned to provoke me to anger
and lo they put the Branch to the nose
which sounds weird but again it's a
branch it's a tree you know to the nose
what do they mean we're going to find
out go one verse um after that and it
says therefore will I also deal in Fury
mine ey shall not spare neither will I
have pity and though they cry in mine
ears with a loud voice yet will I not
hear them so he's so angry this is one
of the things he hates the most yeah and
then I went to the commentaries I wanted
to know what the branch thing meant okay
and he says the branch he mentions is
probably an Ashira a tree or a wooden
pole that stood for the fertility
goddess W it was essentially a phallic
symbol yeah God says that their
wickedness was the same as sticking that
Idol right in his nose right in his face
wow I wonder if that's kind of like
where this goes it's like a branch you
know and you're sticking it to your nose
that's I bet that's like the origin of
that connection and I never thought of
that but yeah okay so here's the whole
Druid thing Julius Caesar is the best
known source of information about The
Druids here again I did not get this
from a Christian site this was a very
raw ulti yeah the raw gist so it's not a
Christian site no and um it says this
comes from the Encyclopedia Britannica
this quote under Druids it clearly
explains who they who they were Druids
the Learned class among the ancient
Kelts whose name means knowing or
finding the oak tree so when you know
somebody as well in the Bible you have
had yeah sexual relations with them
right so this is interesting his wife
yes and I believe that they're that's
what they're referring to yeah um they
seem to have frequented Oak Forest and
acted as priests teachers and judges the
earliest known records of The Druids
come from the 3r century BC Druids took
charge of the public and private
sacrifices and many young men went to
them for instruction they judged all
public and private quarrels and decreed
the penalties the druid's principal
Doctrine was that the soul was Immortal
they offered human victims for those who
were Gravely sick or in danger of death
in battle huge wicker work images were
filled with living men and then
burned through I'm sorry although The
Druids chose criminals by Preference
they sacrificed innocent victims if
necessary um this is talking about
burning man did you put that in here I
did okay I don't want to no no you were
supposed to make that connection yeah
it's talking about the Wicker a a wicker
work image of a man I thought it said
that anyway it did it and burning it
yeah okay so you're going to show that
next no I actually don't have that image
but I was wanting someone to make that
connection so good that's exactly what I
connected when I so it says huge
wickerwork images that's images like
statue so a huge statue made out of
wicker were filled with living men you
put them inside that man and then burned
and now people do that at Raves mhm
connection again Raves Rainman wicker
Druids all these things um but yeah this
is really I hate to I will be having
other more hard-hitting probably videos
I'm not I'm not
um made them or preconceived of them yet
but we will be talking more about
Satanic rituals and Witchcraft and even
police coming across um
reports of how they can tell that it was
satanic right rituals and stuff and this
is what you one of the ways that you
know the world thinks that sat Satanism
and Satanic rituals and stuff like it
never happens anymore but but cops see
it all the time and some of these cops
are involved in these secret societies
so they don't talk about it or they say
they don't report it then they don't
report it in that manner it's like oh
it's gang violence or whatever isn't it
interesting that gangs
go hand in hand with Satanism too look
at the just look up gang graffiti look
it up go to Google search image search
gang graffiti and you will see
pitchforks you'll see 666 you'll see
hexagrams pentagrams and it's just crazy
that people aren't making the connection
that the the gangs are satanic but and
and they're all about murder because
Satan's all about murder but yeah police
they know that there's Satanic rituals
going on satanic sacrifices going on but
it doesn't get reported yeah and I think
it's all a big cover up to make Satanism
look like it's not alive and well today
but it is we hear about you know witch's
covens and their rituals of like we just
read yeah taking innocent victims to do
that with yeah um
so the god an or maybe n or just nut I
don't know was both in Egyptian and
Samaran Canaanite um religions and
it's just kind of a weird goddess but it
was mostly she's mostly depicted in nude
human form sometimes with the form of a
cow again cow bail worship okay yeah
bull whose great body formed the sky and
Heavens a sicamore tree there we go
another tree yeah or as a giant s so a
pig suckling many piglets representing
the Stars pot on the head representing a
uterus so it's always a fertility thing
yeah wow I used to be a
pad crazy all right so next slide I mean
maybe there is a connection with
marijuana being called pot I don't know
but here's where we may not burn
children openly or we not see people do
that but killing
of unfortunately babies and children is
still happening um today it's called
abortion yeah and it happens as late as
birth from what I hear I I have not kept
up with the politics of it but I asked
somebody what is the latest term that
you can have an abortion and somebody
said basically birth up to
birth yeah I heard that recently too and
it was really
disturbing so in bail worship kemos
worship again these are all different
names of the same thing it's all bail
worship baale became known as Kos with
the um where was Esther from I'm sorry
um
I don't remember Queen
Esther no sorry Ruth Ruth Ruth um man I
don't know where that is but that's
anywhere anyway where they called Bale
worship kamos um he's also known as
molock or Marduk so keep that in mind as
well I've heard Marduk too um so yes
instead of burning the children now we
have abortion methods and that is how we
do it all today yeah it's just you know
you go to a a clinic and there's people
wearing uh lab coats and it's all good
you know you you even pay to have it
done it's so clean yeah yeah but they
never they never do show you the aborted
fetus the the quote unquote clump of
cells you know I've had people tell me
it's a clump of cells I've seen what
comes out there's fingernails there's
eyelashes there's a beating heart and
they've done studies to prove that a
baby that young it's nerve are so
sensitive that it feels they feel
feelings 10 times more than humans or
grown adults and they say oh it's it's
not even a human it's a fish and it's
got gills and it's a clump of cells all
these things it's willful ignorance you
can look it up you can look at the the
bodies of the babies and uh this is
happening today people are paying to
have it done the government's paying for
it you know you can get a a government
funded abortion government funded
sacrifice if you will yeah and uh it's
happening in our world and it's
disgusting right it's
yeah
so yeah then there's the pedophilia and
sex trafficking child sex trafficking
specifically that goes along with this
I'm
not I'm just going to make very um like
General
associations but I want to get this
video flagged or taken down or something
yeah but you can go watch uh certain
documentary that's called out of Shadows
and there's also
um fun fact here you cannot send that
link to somebody in messenger I've tried
to send that link I won't even say the
word again but those three words.org if
you try to send that to somebody on
messenger it will not go through you'll
get an error message very
interesting um quiet what is it
quiet okay so there's another one that
um talks about this um but pedophilia
was actually associated with the worship
of Bale Marduk molok and Kash again it
is actually a known fact I didn't I
didn't make any of this up this is all
me in fact every slide is all quotes
from people's websites this is all from
whether it's Satanist websites a cult
websites um pagans themselves who
actually say this is what we do yeah um
or or other Christians that are are
exposing this doing the research yeah um
which really aren't many that's why
again we're talking about this because
really Christians don't know a whole lot
of why they might know one reason and
they're like oh that's that's it but
they don't know the depth of each thing
has so many more reasons why it's done
in paganism and why it glorifies Satan
that we need to know those two like it
really starts um convicting you when you
really know that so if we go back to
that um in yoga yoga is actually um many
different and I'll prove this later we
have a few slides next that actually is
all about sex positions yeah um that's
really what you're practicing for and
worshiping the sun Gods the sun the sun
salutation you look up a list a chart of
the names of these poses and they're
they are like the sun salutation and
then like you're talking about the dog
position and all these things yes um so
the elites um Rothchilds and others
mainly in Bank um all of them really but
in banking especially from this website
um was included that they take part and
so um there's child sex trafficking of
course which is blood sacrifice and CH
of and children sorry blood sacrifice of
children lots of blood was needed it
said by another Pagan source and and
Satan Satanist source that that is
because they need to open this portal of
different dimension which CERN is the
Ark of Baal erected all over the world
in many different places to molok to
maruk different gods like CERN has Shiva
the destroyer and the these guys that
work there are doing all these weird
dances around it and stuff why why is
there this like false idol worship at
this place where there's technology to
open up a portal yeah they say it's the
the
Atom Smasher yeah um but what they're
they say they're trying to reverse
engineer the Big Bang like they want to
basically what this thing is doing it's
a mile long tunnel and it's a magnetic
force field and it slows down particles
to like stop them and then uses magnets
to smash them together and it's a yeah
what do they call that Smasher proton
accelerator something like that and
they're literally as they smash these
things they together
unnaturally things are happening weird
things they're but Adams are bursting
open into new things but there's always
these claims of people that are around
there I remember hearing that some dark
matter they had some dark matter and
they were storing it at some college
campus and people were saying that they
were having night tears and Supernatural
things were happening and I'm sorry I I
started laughing because Star Trek oh
has the movie predictive programing it
has dark matter it
wow and it turns back time oh
interesting so that's kind of what
they're trying to do or dimension in
time try jum but anyway all right
sorry um so they're hoping that this
this God Marduk or molak will come back
and into this new dimension through the
portal and take rulership that's really
what they're looking for and that's what
I was told by the we that's what do
that's what uh Doctor Strange is about
too yes the doctor strange movie Doctor
Strange is Satan if you don't know that
every element of him he's the the black
magician the great sorcerer all these
things he he lives up in the sanctum
sanctuarium sanctuary and and you look
it up that's that's the most holy place
and that's what Satan said I want to be
above the heights of the cloud and when
you see him in that place there's a harp
a big harp of all the instruments that
doctor strange could have there's a harp
which is associated with angels and the
whole story line is
about him uh having this nightmare of a
Stairway to Heaven and he's in a place a
desolate place with bones everywhere and
broken down cities this is explained in
Jeremiah 4:23 through 26 when God's
Fierce anger is going to destroy the
world and Satan's going to be bound to
this desolate Earth for a thousand years
and this is what Satan or this is what
Doctor Strange sorry Satan dror strange
same person this is what his dream his
nightmare is about this reoccurring
Nightmare and in that movie it's all
about the Multiverse and and CERN and
it's not a stretch I read it about it
they said that it was CERN they even
have the false god there and everything
and so I've never seen the movies I
don't know any of the details but the
Multiverse is the spirit realm when you
look it up on the fandom it says that
it's another dimension where there's
this
Multiverse multiversal war going on and
he who remains is the name he who
remains is the one who ends that
multiversal war so it it really is it's
a spiritual war Satan is Doctor Strange
and why did I even say this oh because
of the association with CERN yeah how
when you look at the poster it shows
Doctor Strange stepping through a portal
and I'm like this is what Satan's trying
to do he's trying to step in into our
world as a physical being and deceive
Humanity into thinking he's a
savior yeah Penance to God their God I
guess to shed so much blood that the
portal opens yeah wow man this is crazy
so this is actually it um one of the
depictions of it in uh Rome I think so
this was a portal this is this is an arc
of Bale okay or Arch I'm sorry um what
not sure what which one it is but they
don't usually call it the Ark of Bale or
the arch of Bale they leave that part
off because Bale is not he doesn't have
a good reputation anymore right they'll
actually say it's the ark or arch of
Pala pal is kind of associated with
Babylon and they don't want to say
Babylon either right so in media that's
what they will call it they'll call it
what Pala pal which is sitting again CU
again trees palm palm palm trees yeah
City probably maybe of trees I don't
know I'm stretching there I don't know
but I'm fact Checker yeah maybe there's
a connection there um so this is where
we get into more of this connection
between sex and yoga and sex positions
and so on because when you go back and
look at this many
temples they have many depictions of all
positions basically and beastiality
prostitution and polygamy and everything
you could ever think of but especially
this particular Temple it um is called
the The Temple at
conar and in there you have adultery you
have uh showing orgies oral anal
everything what what is this from this
article or whatever is this this is
extra okay um and someone not Christian
magazine I'm assuming no not at all and
they were just shocked they they were
shocked
as a nonreligious people yeah writing
this just how much disgusting
especially uh every position every type
of of sex available was shown and the
last word there yes even
beastiality yes so these are depictions
in that Temple gra or something um I
purposefully and please be careful with
your own eyes there I do not incl
include many of these
Engravings for a reason um
they they're graphic they're very
graphic yes of all of that but here's
where you find throughout the temple all
of a sudden you would recognize these
poses from yoga yeah um and you're going
huh so this is a sex Temple basically
but why on Earth why would why on Earth
would they have yoga um positions
throughout and this wheel this man this
wheel has all the different
salutations um around the spokes and
that's the wall the whole entire out
outer wall is actually covered by these
wheels interesting that have little
people in the middle of each spokes in a
a certain position involved in yoga
again um to actually greet the sun I
learned when I looked it up it was all
about the positions of the Sun in which
you are glorifying and venerating it wow
so there's that connection there is um
that and so next there's Yoni or
yonic fertility Cults um centered around
female genitalia of
course those gods that are worshiped by
doing so is Diana Ishtar asth aard and
Ashira again it's the same as bail
worship but it's using those different
names and it's using those
poles um as sexual
orgies locations sexual orgy locations
that you can just go and do that
um these are the same as I said as your
this like a strip club yes so that's
where a stripper comes from as well wow
you have the polls you have the rain man
there you know throwing money you got
the connection coming actually full
circle with music and people raving and
you got you know clubs um women Loosely
dressed and so
on um but that's really what's going on
I hate to say it but really what's going
on on Easter Sunday especially when you
go to see the sun come up over the hill
yeah they call it a sunrise service and
churches are doing it and you again the
practice was to catch the Sun Ray as the
sun god appeared so that you could have
this fertility so you you started
jumping into your orgy as soon as
possible how bet there's some people
that even still do it just as a good
luck thing like you know what maybe
maybe we should uh try to have a kid
during the sunrise and you know it's
like I could see a Christian having like
a a lucky rabbit's foot or something and
rubbing it people don't really
understand that this stuff is Pagan it's
not just
some yeah fun thing to do like I I used
to be one of those Christians I was a
when I was my first eight years of being
a Christian I was so naive so ignorant
about so many things that I literally
had Buddha statues and goats and all
kinds I I've always been a a collector
of religious art when I even was before
I was a Christian I loved religious
artist I had candles of Jesus and all
this stuff but I had tarot cards and I
thought you know it's just like a fun
like parlor trick or whatever and magic
eight balls and Ouija boards and all
that stuff had no idea really what I was
messing with and how deep and dark and
demonic those things are yeah I just
thought they were like fun collector
things or
whatever so um just to explain it a
little further it wasn't just that the
common fol
and all the public
could participate in this ritual of the
polls having orgies but it was it became
kind of common place where there were
actually female prostitutes set up to
service you on Easter Sunday
especially um not just in general
worship of
Aira or Anana um they also it's recorded
here that they use knives knives whips
erotic dancing and self mortification so
that's where you get kind of
unforunate yeah you get the
hardcore uh stuff pornographic no yes
and they used lots of pentagrams and
lotus flower depictions for female ayous
sites that's always something that
almost indefinitely
symbolizes uh yanic worship so female
genitalia worship you see that Lotus
everywhere when it comes to like yoga
studios and Eastern medicine yeah
yeah um but it's used in devil worship
all the time in witchcraft of course uh
the I'm just going to read what's there
because I can't take it sometimes it's
used because you want to have deeper
penetration and positions as part of
understanding or sensing new levels of
Devotion to the gods oh wow
um you can even accomplish what you want
to you speak your desire of what you
want fulfilled
you do the ACT um and it it happens it's
a prayer and you seal that prayer with
some sexual ritual that only Satan would
ask for yep and then you probably will
get it because Satan loves to answer
these wishes you know Law of Attraction
all these things it's it's deceived so
many people yes so in the world of Shiva
and Hinduism you have the Kundalini the
serpent Spirit which is directly linked
to this and they actually use both the
phallic symbol and the Yoni which is
where the yoga comes from again this is
not my words um for the practice of
worshipping through sexual rituals
pouring milk on the stone image of the
phallic or phus penetrating the Yoni
which is the lingum that that mound that
we saw yeah that's why you do it it's
part of rituals along with meditation
prayer prayers yoga sexual practice to
achieve
Transcendence marijuana was actually
involved as well interesting food
sacrifices offered to the image of Shiva
and Transcendence is achieved through
deeper penetration like I said and
stretching here's the again you start
realizing they don't care about the
woman they don't care when the knives
and whips and erotic dancing and self
mortification and stretching of the
female organs is involved it is not at
all for any pleasure yeah it is Ser
iously for the goal of transcendence and
Hur you don't care if you hurt the other
person yeah there's like no respect and
it doesn't matter who you have sex with
just do it right it'll be honored it'll
be glorifying to the gods so you know
we're not just talking about all this
stuff because it's like what did all the
pagans used to do we're showing how this
is still prevalent in society today it's
accepted marijuana
smoking uh homosexual uality anal sex
all these things the the holidays that
people are still participating in the
yoga I mean this stuff is when you say
these words it's like yeah that's our
culture today this isn't stuff that used
to happen a long time ago or you
know um it's just been veiled and Satan
is deceiving everyone into doing these
things and thinking it's okay and now
it's you know in schools Christian
schools are doing yoga and meditation
and mindfulness and all this stuff and
churches yeah churches are doing it come
to my church we're doing yoga yeah uh
we're learning all the different sex
positions and sun salutations and it's
just insane that this is happening in
churches
um yeah we're just doing that to the
image of God or to Bible verses which
you can't put two in two together oh you
can't um so I'm just going full circle
when I did this study it was actually a
study I did imagine that um of why we
have so much junk in the world why all
of the pain why all of the heartache
where did all this come from and so I
found out that pornography of course and
you see that throughout all of paganism
like Mikey said it's all naked bodies
it's a part of all sexual practices of
the Gods seeing an inciting lust and
mimicking the sexual behaviors you see
looking at the statues and doing it M um
all of this proceeds from Bale because
it's where it came from it was the first
pattern of of doing this W um so with
rape there you have it Isis and Islam
and Hinduism with Zeus Marduk and
satanic sexual practices or rituals
that's all I'm going to say about that
war and killing actually has its place I
didn't I mean you think about it on a
very disgusting level a more criminal
and disgusting mind type level you would
think that of course it Happ has a place
but
um I didn't really want to know as much
as they told me here but we'll just go
into it all blood sacrifices human
animal or other are made to conjure
forces that collectively relate to
satanic and bamit underworld Realms used
by satanists witches luciferians Voodoo
Islam along with drugs to allow one's
body to be possessed by spirits to give
control and feed into Satan's power you
know how many soldiers actually were
doing opium and all this stuff so they
yeah literally do opium be possessed by
demons and go out there and kill each
other Satan is just orchestrating this
whole thing like a puppet master
yes um so the ult actually uses
sacrifice and killing to cause
disassociation trauma abuse numbness if
you will to develop split personalities
and P perverse coping mechanisms the MK
Ultra stuff yep to make sociopaths
Psychopaths and open doors to being used
by Satan further in anger and hurt or
mental
illness okay so then we have population
control which I was kind of shocked to
find myself I was not under I didn't
know if it was real or not but here we
go um it says and you you can always go
look at my sources it says A New World
Order Plan to kill others deemed
unnecessary so it's killing others of
that are deemed unnecessary to the world
right um those who are that means
they're giving that definition of who
those people are those who are not in
the elite
group or the inner group if you really
want to State the truth there they they
state it the inner group of bail worship
they call them the useless eaters that's
who we are I see because we're not in
the club um Walter VI calls it the goyam
you can look up that and it has a lot
more you can look up on that too but um
zionists call
us but they're using toxins of course
air pollutants birth control
sterilization you name it biological
warfare anything against us so I can
think of a few things uh chemicals being
spread in the air chemicals being spray
on the food
genetically manipulating the food
abortion making homosexuality seem cool
all this is population control the more
people who are homosexual the less
people create the more you divide people
you less people are even in
relationships anymore not you know LGBT
aside just in general less people are
having physical interactions
everything's digital people aren't in
relationships anymore less people are
having kids because they're focused on
work or whatever the whole thing is
population control abortion the
pharmaceutical industry yeah uh all the
toxics yeah I mean so clear that Satan
is trying to destroy the world he is the
one who comes to seek kill and destroy
and he wants to lower the population so
it's at a controllable manner for this
new world order
yes yeah so there's just a depiction of
it
um
drinking this is part of dianis Shiva
Odin Voodoo and
hudo um I didn't know if you guys knew
that but h is actually another name for
Voodoo yeah I have heard that um it's a
part of faith for pagans to do to honor
their gods and
ancestors um it's used to invoke Spirits
in ritual or ceremonial practices pagans
EMP emphasize drinking in moderation to
keep balance of the good and evil or yin
and yang oh my goodness or so on within
themselves there's also luciferian
brewing and malting handycraft beers you
know I'm a little too good I need a
little
evil to balance out so let me drink some
you know I think it's interesting that
it's called craft beer craft yes craft
beers oh witchcraft beers right yes
being handy of course I don't think
there's anything wrong with that word
but it has taken on that meaning
especially in witchcraft you can be as
we use it in in Hobby Lobby I love doing
crash I like being handy right right
that means you can do all kinds of
things you might be good at weaving
sewing whatever that's not bad but it's
what it's used for and unfortunately
that term was taken by the witches they
they're quite handy people I'm saying
there's a there's a type of beer called
craft beer yes and if beer is the same
as Spirits you got craft and spirits and
the same thing it's like he doesn't even
hide man yeah so anyway there's that
then the hexagram a symbol used to
invoke demons it's not just a symbol it
is used for that the hexagram is what
people know today as the Star of David
it's not a star of David there's no
nothing in the Bible about David having
any Star it's a Sixpoint star it's an
ancient occult symbol and it's it's
satanic and it's crazy that Satan has
deceived and duped the Christian world
where they all have that symbol on their
cars and bumper stickers and flags even
and they're saying stand with Israel and
all this stuff stand with the Zionist
with your hexagram six-pointed star well
that's the um one of the points I I make
in the pagan origins video because or
presentation because
because hexagram takes on many forms
throughout history as well it doesn't
have to be a full uh pointed star up or
down or whatever and you're just like oh
there it
is sometimes it doesn't even have a
circle around it sometimes it doesn't
have all of its points all these things
but it's still the same thing they're
hiding it they're deceiving you so I
mean it's on the back of the dollar bill
if you
trace uh if you look at the the the
pyramid and then you trace it actually
spells the word Mason if you make if you
connect the dots and point there's words
there and you connect M to a to S to O
and just in case you didn't know who was
in control
yeah um yeah so it's used to actually
invoke demons called
bamit um or cabala it's used in cabala
to put hexes on others that's why you
say that um the origin is the hexagram
shape that's on top of Saturn from NASA
isn't that interesting Saturn worship
coming in here wait a minute so what
does this mean um NASA shows a picture
of Saturn it's got a hexagram on it or
something we're gonna see one in a
minute okay I have I have heard that
they believe that the core of Saturn is
a cube or a black Cube or something by
the way I don't believe in any of this
junk I don't believe the NASA I don't
believe that they know the core of any
planet is ridiculous that anybody
believes it but I'm just going to throw
that out there yes um
so yeah like he said we're gonna
actually see that Cube of Saturn or that
eye the allseeing eye um in a minute but
it's used in hexagram is used in
Hinduism yoga spiritualism witchcraft
Etc um originally from Saturn worship so
that's where it's put in um by the way
there's a little connection a little
tidbit I'll give you Saturn worship or
the god of Saturn which is named Kronos
or even um
let's just say St Nicholas oh wow he is
the god of of Saturn is actually known
to change times and laws wow so there's
a god of time that's why most of the
time sheets that you have to fill out as
an employee most places their time clock
or their program for it is called Kronos
wow you know there's a interesting thing
about you said St Nick do you know that
Nick is a name for Satan I didn't know
that but you can you can Google it
anybody can say it um I I'll just ask
Google real quick who is old
Nick according to vocabulary.com
definitions of old Nick noun Chief
Spirit of evil and adversary of God
tempter of mankind master of hell and
then it stops but it says
synonym uh be elub devil Lucifer Prince
of Darkness Satan the tempter that's who
Nick is um old Old St Nick and you know
Nickelodeon the show that everybody
watches now they're just Nick you go to
nick.com takes you to Nickelodeon which
the Bible actually speaks specifically
about the nians and how much God hates
the nielan so much and what is
Nickelodeon known for now with these
documentaries coming out quiet onet Nick
is known for abusing children which is
complete Satan worship so you got this
whole Goliath of a network that's all
focused on children and the actors are
being abused and they're promoting
they're programming children with this
company called Nick Nick at night and
and these connections aren't coincidence
they're actually nods to each other
again of biblical reference like we're
saying of like God hated the nicla what
did they do probably the same thing that
Nickelodeon's doing to Children right
and so on what what are things that God
really hates it's well he says that if
you defile a young child that you should
have a millstone Millstone hung around
your neck and thrown into the sea like
Jesus loves the little children right
and yeah I guarantee the nicolan are
doing that junk
too okay so um the hexagram ironically
again the symbol of the Jewish star or
starve David is not at all that it was
used by Hitler's friend named
Rothchild even though it is the star of
ran and I you might never have heard of
that but the Bible specifically which I
think the next slide is actually where
the Bible is quoting what the star of
rampan is it's found in Amos 5 26 verse
2 uh 6 and 27 acts 7 verse 43 please
look that up um but star of ran is
actually the eight- pointed star also
known to be associated with the Roman
God Saturn there you go again and
possibly the Babylonian goddess Ishtar
again this was the internet giving me
this but their interesting connections
they're drawing lead us right back to
where we were we we've been studying
this tonight um pentagram itself is a
five-pointed star of course we know that
um the occultt pentagram is an inverted
fivepoint star inside of a circle
someone wrote in here that um it's a
triangle within a triangle yeah that is
true as well
but the Star of David at the very bottom
here that we were speaking of is used in
many ancient cultures you'll find that
again in in many of the drawings and
Engravings in places for decorative
purposes but it held
significance mainly because it's the
star of molok if you actually go look it
up that's exactly what I was looking up
right now yes um people say Masons
mainly say that this is a
a symbol that Solomon had on his ring
and he could control demons I don't know
where they get that might be true
because he went so far into the demon
and Witchcraft World by worshiping other
gods and Idols true I don't I don't
think that that might be false it might
be true but a lot of people are actually
trying to mimic the kind of sorcery and
depth of wickedness that Solomon got
himself into yeah and rebuild his Temple
and all that that's what the Masons are
trying to do that Mason what are they
building with bricks and Mason trying to
rebuild his Temple yeah I I looked up
star of molok and the AI gave me this
you know a i Google Now is using AI but
it says the star of molok is a star
mentioned in the Bible in the Book of
Amos
5:26 and Acts of the Apostles 743 in a
context that suggests I
Idis wait idolatrous I don't know
worship idolatrous worship the star is
associated with the worship of Idols
including and um this picture that it
gives literally is
showing Crossing out the the the
hexagram the Star of David quote unquote
and if you if you click on images to see
what images you get all the images are
that picture that is the star of Molech
so you know the Bible never talks about
a star of David but it talks about a
star of Molech right and you look it up
that's what it is it's the hexagram and
Satan has duped Humanity again duped the
Christians again to where we're all
flying that flag and stand with Israel
and I don't even believe that Israel is
the Israel from the Bible these white
guys with the little curly locks these
are not Israel this is Zionist these are
Zionist elitists who are trying to take
over the world um true Israelite is most
likely dark skinned and not the people
that you think of as the Jewish
Nation um so this is Saturn this is
supposed to be that um picture from NASA
of the cube yes it is the North Pole of
Saturn the cube on it but it's also
supposed to be the allseeing eye I've
heard some Pagan um blog stating that it
actually is when you unravel the cube it
becomes the cross
um and I think there's connection there
as well I think that actually was a nod
even way back when when Jesus was
crucified on it that it wasn't just the
cross of tamuz which yeah pagans
crucified him to that cross and I think
there was significance to that cross yes
even to Saturn I believe so um because
they worshiped Saturn openly they
worship Mercury Jupiter Saturn um Venus
all of these planets um anyway next
slide we could go to um again touches on
this again because it's so important it
seems
so so prevalent yeah in bail worship
we're going to talk about this obscene
sex rituals such as anal and oral are
from Bale peor now Bale peor is a moabit
God that's another thing think thank God
so Ruth was a moabit she prepared
children for Kash the this burning of
the children she actually prepared
children to go and be sacrificed as Ruth
did she did oh wow that was her job in
the Palace of the king oh my and so when
she would she would brainwash them it
was her job to groom groom the children
to believe it was a a honor to die for
Kos wow and for the entire city to live
and have fertility and harvest and
plenty and so Ruth knows about this she
had to give it up which I don't know how
dep deep she was in it of course she was
deep because she was grooming children
yeah and they didn't um it was like an
annual or a festive thing where they
would choose one special person child
who had no blemish on them and
everything they had all these things
they had to be a counterfeit of what God
was requesting God would never ask for a
child sacrifice right and there but
Satan's using that same thing a kid
without blemish all this stuff mhm even
that terminology kid yeah that that got
entered into our culture I hardly ever
use that word kid but um they're
children yeah a kid is a goat and I
think it's interesting that we're
calling our children kids it's become
our vernacular so I don't yeah I never
thought about it when I saw it I didn't
know this about Ruth this is interesting
but this is why I fell in love with this
woman
she's she can teach me and it's just I
love that we can do shows like this and
who would have known yeah um so that's
where it comes from again but it's it's
Bale payor is actually a mount where the
Jews when they entered in and they saw a
lot of the pagans around them worshiping
and having these orgies they actually
set up their own altar unfortunately and
they began at Bale peor in this Valley
I'll show a picture of what it looks
like today um soon but
um it's where they started sacrificing
their own children to baale um and it's
used it was used or is still um in
Hinduism and Shiva worship of using
different positions for sex like that in
Kundalini um for the fertility Cults of
the yoga of yoga um next slide and this
is where the Bible verse I I didn't just
say that this happened in
history this actually happened in the
Bible follow along with me here it says
and Israel bowed in shum which is sorry
for that but I think there's a
connection happening where that cuss
word came from Yes um and the people
began to commit whoredom with the
daughters of Moab so moabit moabitas
Ruth moabit God and they called the
people unto the sacrifices of their gods
and the people did eat and bowed down to
their gods and Israel joined herself
onto Bor so Bale peor is like another
variation of baale but they're going to
tell you what it means we're going to
get into it and the anger of the Lord
was kindled against Israel and the Lord
said unto Moses take all the heads of
the people and hang them up before the
Lord against the Sun that the fierce
anger of the Lord may be turned away
from Israel and Moses said unto the
judges of Israel slay ye
everyone this his men that were joined
unto Bor so here we're going to get rid
of it within our group and behold one of
the children of Israel came and brought
unto his Brethren a Midian itish woman
in the sight of Moses in the sight of
all the congregation of the children of
Israel who were weeping before the door
of the Tabernacle of the congregation
and when Phineas the son of Eleazar the
son of Aaron the priest saw it he rose
up from among the congregation and took
a javelin in his hand and he went after
the man of Israel into the tent and
thrust both of them through the man of
Israel and the woman through her belly
so the plague was stayed they calls it a
plague why because here's a connection
the Bible tells you continually not
marry
people who
are foreign the foreign women it says
unequally yoked which means basically
don't bring idol worship into your life
and don't pagans who don't worship God
paganism yeah and it is something we
have to be careful of but once it
happened in
Israel to cleanse it unfortunately God
does this many times and I'm not going
to speak for him don't ask me why or how
he can justify doing that but he does he
cleanses usually his people by doing
that well it's yeah it's like cancer you
know you could a doctor tells you you
have a lump and you're like you know
what just leave it there I don't want to
be U intrusive I don't want to be a
hater or intolerant of the cancer no you
want it cut out you know off of your
body because it's going to spread
yeah in the same way this has happened
in these cultures and God knew it go he
knows the beginning from the end and it
is it is tough to you know understand
and everything but that was the reason
right so there it is there's proof
straight from the Bible numbers 25 verse
1-9 and what God says to do about it
um when we set up the United States and
there was freedom of religion
we had to be tolerant of all these
things no it was
law it's true but God tells us and I'm
not trying to be mean I'm not trying to
be hurtful or any anything I don't think
we should be I'm not wanting to be a
killer or anything right I'm just saying
that God is going to cleanse his people
he's coming again it's going to happen
but right now there's time for the
Gentiles the word to go out to all the
Gentiles there's people in every Walk of
Life who are in this or whatever ever
they're
into which God is reaching out to and he
he has an opportunity for them to come
back to him and be in heaven amen he say
come out my people he's calling them his
people but we're involved in Pagan type
things yes so um I think that's that's
yeah the same one we were I wanted to
include this because this again that was
the Bible now we're going to actually
Hebrew and we're going to look at the
words Bale again it means owner or Lord
and then peor actually means to open
wide and in the context of what we're
looking at it was all body openings and
orifices right so he's Lord of all of
the
orifices or Lord of the openings as it
said I didn't get any of this from my
own mouth this was all quotes and it
says AKA today he's God of the
holes okay so that's what it was about
this is actually the Mount of bail pay
today the ashir poles and they're still
there wow yeah that's like in the middle
of nowhere exactly on some Mountain wow
which is where people try to meet God
you know on the mountain
so so here's a connection I found um in
the Babylonian talmood which is
interesting Hebrews Jews usually have a
tal right well when when you follow the
calendar through the Hebrew calendar
they have all the same names for every
month as the Babylonian
calendar and then they have and I found
out through this very research here you
have a talmood that's Hebrew and a
talmood that is
Babylonian wow so where did the talmood
really you know what I mean why are
there why are there two for
different cultures why they have the
same it's like the Holy Bible and
Satanic Bible yeah so but they're both
bad in this case take that as you will
maybe research it for yourself whatever
but I'm going to look into it more um
but it says in that book one story in
the Sanhedrin part of the talmud the
rabinal interpretation of the tanak
tanak yeah tells of sabta a Jew who
attempted to show his contempt for bpor
sabat defecated in the temple and
cleaned himself on the Statue only to be
Comm commended for his efforts he then
entered uncovered himself before it and
wiped off on the night Idol's nose
whilst the
aites praised him saying one man no man
has ever served this Idol thus oh my
goodness Rashi a French Rabbi of the
late 11th century said of bpor that they
would uncover before it so it was part
of their practice he didn't even know
that he was actually mimicking their
very practice he was trying to defile it
and they were like wow what a great
service you've done yes worshiping the
God oh my goodness exactly they would
actually uncover before at the end of
the rectum and bring forth excrement I'm
quote I'm just reading what to there
again th this is its Worship in light of
this we should be grateful that it was
the Israelites God who won this
particular battle and who went on to
create the dominant religion of the
world you know that's something else
I've seen in these satanic occult
circles is they eat feces yes they do
and
so that is crazy you know Satan he's
trying to make it the most disgusting
things and that's why you have things
like anal sex that involve feces and
everything yes so moving on from that
even I wanted to even know why people
have
cussing why where did that come from
they call it curse words too you know
yes cursing um so it was actually from I
don't know where the earliest mention of
it but I actually found a goddess
dedicated to this uh to curses and her
name is
curone she would invoke Demons by
cursing to disperse evil on others when
cursed in her name known for pronouncing
curses on others in this way it's used
in wiah all the time but you don't just
say it in peron's name in movies they do
this all the time have you noticed I
don't know okay what they do we might
show a quote or something if we could
put this together later but in in movies
they'll actually
say they'll pronounce a curse like in
this God's name curses this this this
this and this and bring destruction upon
this enemy and blah blah blah you can
choose whatever God you want right to
back that curse up but you're really
just asking a demon to do it yeah so
they do that um it's used in wi of
Witchcraft paganism
spiritualism and satans who fully
understand they are honoring person and
these other gods when they do it they're
believing in it they're trusting in them
they're giving the power to do it that
is crazy because most of the time people
cuss when they're so angry and like it's
become so popular that people do it all
the time now it's like when they rap or
when they whatever is just part of an
everyday
life but it's it's demonic if it if you
have so much rage that this comes out of
your mouth but then it becomes every day
normal that's a problem
yes and um here's meditation I know that
the Bible tells us to meditate on God
word and and fill our hearts with things
that are pure and lovely and all those
things but a counterfeit of that is
actual practice of
meditation at the core of Hinduism
Buddhism judaic
cabalism um Islam and from the
roots and from The Roots have leaked
into Christianity yeah trying to unite
worshiping other gods with worshiping
Christ that's really they're telling you
exactly why you do it and meditation is
a Biblical thing but Satan has perverted
that yes so quickly here you can see all
the gods mentioned for phallic fertility
Cults um of course Aeros is for the
ayous sex points that's why we have
ayous it's name
itself
um let's see here Deon that's the the
fish that you see on the the pope Hermes
the Pope that wears that hat that tall
hat is a fish head and it has a cape and
that's exactly what deeon wore yes
Hermes um there's the actual Cross of
Hermes that the pope wears on his sleev
sometimes or on his
vestages
um so Min is also one of them it's a
Chinese god which
introduces maybe he's not the first one
but masturbation especially fondling and
caressing of the
phallic and um a whip in the other so he
was actually shown in this whip whenever
he was doing stuff to himself and others
and thus it comes into place that
whipping sexually is okay sex and
drunkenness for Transcendence and
gagging which um you can read it there
I'm not going to say the rest yeah um
raving and clubbing again we we tie that
to cbel but it's also in satalia Pagan
feast in honor of of Saturn which was a
week-long feast December 17th through
the 23rd kids were off school slay
slaves and servants were off gambling
and blood sacrifices drinking loud music
crossdressing any and all sexual license
was
there wow only you were only to wear
your undergarments and Dolls were given
out representing remains of human
sacrifice to Saturn blood pudding was
eaten to represent the blood itself of
the sacrifice it was a precursor to what
we now call Christmas that is what
these celebrities are doing this Spirit
cooking stuff and they have this cake
that looks like a human body and there's
like this blood coming out of it yes and
many wonder if that's real or fake in
the sense of it really is happening
these pictures are really posted on
Twitter and all that but um people
wonder if the the blood is
real yeah this is a a picture of
depicting the Raves these were this was
the most tame picture I could find and
most you know appropriate yeah so yes it
would look like that and I do believe it
was kind of like a mesh of people all
around themselves over themselves having
these relations
yeah um the last one we come to is TV
and video games and screens this is
actually a connection which shocked me
it does have direct connections to
Saturn's Black Cube look that up please
go look it up it's also aka the swastika
hexagram it equals 666 when you add it
up again which was also the cross
two triangles over another someone
mentioned the Seal of King Solomon as he
called upon demons Masonic symbols
papacy symbols skull and crossbones the
allseeing eye Saturn god of death time
and judgment AKA law and time laws and
times bail worship Kronos and reman as
mystical stories of Saturn goes known
he's known for eating his children and
he went to do so which his wife then
offered him a large black stone instead
so that he devoured it a replacement oh
W it's also known as Pandora's Box which
correlates to the veil being ripped
before Caiaphas and ananas who hated
Christ and put him to
death um who tortured and killed Jesus
supposedly the veil ripped in as a sign
in the sign of a cross folded and became
a cube or box opening the veil or
mysteries of God became behind the veil
was to open Pandora's Box all or all the
Abominations of the earth what do we do
we we actually see all the abom are
broadcasted through screens yeah your
phone your TV um whatever
screens and I think Satan set that up so
that we could indge is a Pandora's box
it is a tree of knowledge you know God
wanted to keep us from that tree of
knowledge of Good and Evil and now we
have these devices with access to
anything anything in the world and
ironically the phone has that apple on
it with a B taken out of it you're using
that device the tree of knowledge to see
all this stuff and you type www to get
to whatever you want to look at and www
is Hebrew for 666 the every letter is
associated with a number and so that's
the VAV that's the Hebrew 6 so we're
typing 666 on a device with a bit apple
with a tree of knowledge to see anything
we want all the dark things we want to
see m
and it's like we're just reliving this
whole thing again well and they did that
on purpose to speed up our um
indoctrination yeah right they want
their ruler to come and they want us all
to be a part of it and asleep to it all
right and so it's like just allow them
to view everything and anything it
really quickly everything on demand yeah
we'll do that so just to finish this off
because it's a lot
um where were we oh it's a symbol of the
Caba or Allah in Mecca when they go in
the pilgrimage around it in Islam the
cube or cube with a K symbolizes the
emblem of the progyny of Abraham which
was rejected by the Israelites and
became the Cornerstone of what they
think the kingdom of God is or ishmael's
descendants this is where um this verse
comes to mind Psalm
118:22 the stone which the builders
refused is become the The Headstone of
the corner the Masons quote that all the
time
mhm interesting Capstone so here this
person wrote more and I didn't have
space on the slide so here we have an
actual depiction of what he's saying he
said that the black stone fell from the
sky originally one of the precious
stones of Heaven which Satan was covered
in all these precious stones but that
God deprived it of its Brilliance which
would have illuminated the world from
one end to the other aka the Holy Grail
coined by the Nazis
which explored Explorer I'm sorry Otto
Ron who called The Stone Lucifer's Grail
originally folklore is that you see the
stone and you get eternal life that
might be the Pagan's view on on these
things and Satanist views but a box of
viewing and learning all Abominations
containing all the evil of mankind or
the box of the unnatural and confinement
ironically following all these teachings
and everything becomes a cube you are
shut up in WoW
lost and confused a prison cell to
separate man from God while trying to
fit everything inside the box we have
become imprisoned this symbol is a
symbol of human
oppression this up here that says uh
that a black stone fell from the sky
that is at Mecca that's right which is a
Black Cube and inside that thing they
have this black stone that came from the
sky and they all worship it they you
know run circles around that thing and
worship which ironically did you show a
picture of that it's right there I put a
little it actually on this last slide PR
previous slide it was a little
tiny yes Emoji oh my goodness what
happening um and so it's there but also
cybel a lot of the followers of
cbel um had a black Cube that was her
symbol was a Black Cube which again I'm
I'm just going to make the
correlation the Jews wear a black Cube
on their head yeah supposedly to remind
them of the laws but if you really look
deeper not only do the Islamic people
have the Black Cube that they're
pilgrimages into Judaism and you also
have it in Catholicism so look that up
as well um it's an interesting study no
that's it that's it in entirety yes it
is but this is a showcase this is for us
to get a well it's quite deep but it's
also very general when you really are
speaking of it so that we understand how
to identify bail Worship in our culture
today right and it's you
know this stuff hasn't gone away it's
just got a new disguise That's what
Satan loves to do is disguise MH
paganism and Satan worship in a way that
looks fun hey Halloween it's about about
dressing up and candy and knocking on
doors and it's all a satanic practice
and then we're going to learn it's about
Easter and Christmas and all these other
holidays that we've even christianized
yeah and you got the Raves you got women
that are dancing for the Rainman to
throw
money um the
mapole all these things are just
sugarcoated and made to be culture and
acceptable and the homosexual lifestyle
I mean really I
see Satan building his kingdom He is
building it and that just means that
Christ is coming soon I see the world
spinning out of control I
see people don't even bat an eye anymore
at blatant wickedness it's been so
accepted now and a huge part of it is
the media the influence of the media I
believe that this world would not be the
way it is if television didn't exist if
phones didn't ex if there was no media
and I'm not saying it's all the media
I'm not saying that media is all evil
and all evil comes from media but I'm
saying that we live in a culture that
says whatever is on the screen is
reality and life imitates art we see
that and we're like oh that's what a
family is supposed to do oh that's
what's cool oh the dude on stage is
wearing those shoes I got to wear that
she's wearing that bag I got aware that
I think that's a interesting connection
you're making that what we see in art is
like a model for us to pattern our life
after because Alistar Crowley actually
writes that that's how you actually can
indoctrinate and channel um demons and
so on by actually looking at art and
following it whoa okay yeah that is
interesting aliser Crowley also
practiced all this sex magic all these
yeah he was a pedophile he was a
homosexual
and it just ties back to what the stuff
is so I pray you guys were you know
edified in some way I pray that your
eyes were opened you know if you know
people that are messing around with yoga
or who are you know a homosexual Ally
you know now we're being allies like
well I'm not one but I stand for you
know love and all these things this is a
deception on a worldwide scale and Satan
is this Dragon who's deceiving the world
through media is a huge tool of his and
the world is just reaching the end and I
believe that Jesus is coming soon I
believe we need to share the truth far
and wide things like this use the
internet while it's still free and
accessible and and not completely
censored use it to reach the world if
you don't have any kind of material no
presentation share your testimony do
something do something with your life
life to where you're being used by God
in some way and that you can expand his
kingdom when he comes that's why we're
doing what we're doing we started this
ministry five weeks ago and I praise God
that he's provided for us to do these
things to be able to have the equipment
we need to uh be able to make our bills
and it's it's a struggle but we are
trusting in God we know that he's called
us to do this we know that he's put us
together and that we have this Ministry
and so we need your support it's this
doesn't this doesn't just happen on its
own if if bills don't get made then we
got to get jobs again and and this
channel shuts down so if you want to
support this ministry you can do so by
going to some of these we got cash app
we have vinmo zel we have PayPal if you
want to buy a t-shirt you can go to uh
our Teespring and buy a t-shirt with a
logo and that you know we'll get five
bucks off of a shirt or something but
there's many ways you can support this
ministry even just by sharing the video
liking the video commenting on the video
all those things help this video get
onto the algorithm which can help the
channel grow and right now we're not
even monetized we could be but um we're
hoping to just be able to depend on your
support and I've been amazed and blessed
that the people who have already before
we even really had anything to show have
been saying what's your Channel I want
to support you guys and so we're doing
this for you guys um we could keep this
information to oursel but we want the
whole world to know that um well to see
through deception we've both been
deceived we've both been on the other
side of this and we don't want to see
other people fall into these traps you
know if you saw your friend walking
towards a cliff you would warn them
because you wouldn't want them to get
hurt and fall into that
trap did you have something you were
going to say I just want to reemphasize
like I have moments U speaking on this
topic is this isn't thrill me to talk
about any of
this disgusting details but it Thrills
me to expose deception so
that it's like a a door is unlocked yeah
you're no longer stuck in that you can
be freed of it too even if it wasn't
some like huge um prison you felt you
were locked in or that you're
participating in there's things you
didn't know that are actually a part of
this worship that you are now aware of
yeah that you can be freed of of
participating unknowingly in we actually
have friends that said I watched that
program because this was she already
gave this presentation before and these
are Christian friends and they're like
you talked on something that we were
practicing and we no longer do it
because we know where it comes from yeah
and it wasn't yoga any of those things
that stuff's happening in churches too
so you know I just pray that this was
eye openening and that if you're
practicing any of this stuff any of it
to pray and ask God to deliver you from
these things get these things out of
your home because you will not regret it
you'll you'll have a closer relationship
with God you'll you'll be um you know
the Bible says flee from what say resist
the devil and he will flee from you yeah
so as we resist him by getting rid of
his distractions his uh Idols all these
things he will flee from us and that's
the best thing that could ever happen to
us so right we love you we thank you for
being a part of this uh Pres
presentation we hope that you'll give it
a thumbs up it really helps click the
notif or click the Subscribe and the
notification Bell so that you won't miss
a video we're going to try to go live as
much as possible we don't have any kind
of schedule we just want to do this more
than once a week even and um we hope
that you guys will be blessed by it and
that's something that you can share with
your family and friends we love you and
God bless and we'll see you next time